the word disabled athlete I absolutely
hate it I don't look at myself as
disabled at all I have a disability
everybody in this world has a disability
of some sort but you're only disabled if
you believe you are I'm just an athlete
that needs a couple extra tools this
great big story was made possible by
Geico believe it
Geico could save you 15% or more on car
insurance my competitive history started
out on a BMX bike when I was like 13
years old which quickly evolved into
motocross and then got into racing
snowmobiles at the peak of my pro career
I had finished fourth place in the
national championship series I'd landed
on the podium a handful of times in 2008
during a qualifying race in northern
Michigan I was thrown from my machine
which caused a compound fracture that
severed the main artery that feeds my
lower leg it was apparent three days
later that amputation was the only way
to basically save my life I was floored
I mean I didn't see it coming at all my
profession and livelihood is to be
racing a snowmobile or a dirt bike you
know initially I'm like I'm gonna be
done racing I'm gonna be done competing
but about five weeks after the injury
had happened I got to try out my new
prosthetic leg the first leg that I got
it worked okay for walking it was really
basic mechanical leg actually got on my
snowmobile within a week or so of
getting it and right away I understood
that yeah this leg is definitely not
gonna be the ticket for me to get back
into the sports that I love I was
presented with this problem basically I
needed to absorb impact with my leg like
my quadricep muscles do I know
suspension components from the dirt
bikes and snowmobiles so I'm looking at
this as a suspension component I've
needed shock a spring and a frame to
hold it all and make it move in the
directions I needed to move
and I drew on it for about five weeks or
so just pencil sketches and pages and
pages of designs and then from there I
went to the shop and started cutting
part I had all the pieces and assemble
it put it on my leg and then immediately
went over to my dirt bike and went for a
ride seven months after my accident I
was racing dirt bikes on a leg that I
built in my garage the original moto
knee was developed for me to get back on
my dirt bike and that summer after
meeting a whole bunch of other amputees
I realized that there's so many other
people that can utilize the equipment I
was working on so I started thinking
about creating a company around it the
coolest part about what I'm doing is it
allows me to continue to be an athlete
so I do all the testing on the racetrack
and the practice track which gets me
into a lot of new stuff as well like
snowboarding it turns out I got pretty
good at it I enjoyed it got talked into
competing for the first time and that
evolved into traveling around the world
on the World Cup tour and earning my
spot on the 2018 Paralympic snowboarder
team and won a gold medal and border
cross and a silver medal and bang slalom
and I'm a nine-time X Games gold
medalist between adaptive racing and
dirt bike snowmobiles and now snow bikes
you know I've kind of reached my goals
with all that so this year I'm gonna
step it up a notch and I'm gonna try and
qualify into the pro snow bike race I
tell you what it really sucks to be an
amputee sometimes but there's so many
different amazing things that I've been
able to experience since my injury
happen I'm making the most of the
situation and I'm still living life to
the fullest
[Music]